what film has kind of changed everything
for you in your career what was that
kind of pivotal film
I got a I mean a couple of uh I guess
Peaks certainly it was Ridley and Gina
bringing me into film and Louise that
was kind of my first shot in the big
leagues as I call it and I just kind of
watched on in and I'd say ladies
Gentlemen let's see a win's prize
keeping her cool Simon Says everybody
down on the floor um then certainly
meeting David Fincher what's in the
[__] box that was what I was always
hoping it would be and that that set me
off in a really really good direction
letting yourself become
Tyler and from there I just been groping
my way through it
I'm doing all right thank you